it's a little what's more likely for the
two games to be played on sunday let's
begin with buccaneers at packers what's
more likely oh aaron rodgers throws
three or more touchdown passes or
one or more interceptions
christopher right well we know that was
the that was the only game this year
right that he threw multiple
interceptions and he almost threw half
his yearly total in that game itself
aaron rodgers
i believe has the most pressure on him
this weekend over any other player
that's playing this is a big game for
aaron rodgers this is tom brady he's on
the bucks he's on a new team and now
he's going to get a chance to go to the
another super bowl
and you haven't been back to a second
one yet you know i don't i you know how
i view it but that's the the theme out
there and to me this is a legacy type
win that is definitely more important to
rogers than brady in the big scope of
things right if brady loses this no
one's gonna really care everyone's gonna
go it's an amazing year man brady at 43
they went to the nfc championship game
they haven't been to the playoffs since
2007. he's already won the year he's
good rogers is in that oh man he's great
but how it's a shame they've never made
it to more than one super bowl with him
and you know how great is he he didn't
win you know win super bowls and all
those type of things i'm gonna say if
you make me pick either one i'm gonna go
three plus touchdowns because i think
he's gonna be ultra careful with the
football and realize legacy's on the
line he will not throw more than one
interception he might throw one but i
don't think it's gonna be
more than that i'm gonna go three tds
there
yeah i uh if you make me pick i'm gonna
pick it
yeah i agree with you i agree with you
because i think about that secondary
they're young yeah um you've got devante
adams i i just i don't know whether or
not we're going to see that same
buccaneers defense that we saw in the
second half is it going to make an
appearance
earlier than it did against the saints
is going to be there from the get-go how
is the cold going to affect them but
unless you get that that bucks defense
in the zone that they were in led by
devon white and also antoine winfield jr
i think we're gonna see aaron rodgers do
aaron rodgers things and you know we're
talking about that urgency that he's
feeling as he tries to get to his second
career super bowl i was doing a little
work last night on on the officials
lockout from nine years ago and what a
mess that was you know once it ended we
kind of purged it out of our brains
right it was a mess that was an
embarrassment for the nfl it was one of
the most embarrassing episodes of the
last 20 years for the nfl
but when you look at the fail mary game
the monday night and i know it's
impossible to do apples to apples but
you take away that loss that the packers
got that should have been a win
all other things equal they get a buy
that year they get the division around
game at home
yeah they had a lost year
that you could trace directly to the
official's lockout and and if i was a
packers fan i'd still be pissed about
that sorry london nine years later all
right buccaneers at packers another one
what's more likely and this relates to
the whole aaron rodgers dynamic plus the
great packers offensive line even
without david bachtiari bucks get three
or more sacks or they're held to one
sack of aaron rodgers he was sacked zero
times last week in the win over the rams
despite the presence of aaron donald but
four times against the tampa bay
buccaneers in week six so what's more
likely three or more or one well i this
is this is gonna have to be in aaron
rodgers throwing the football game i i
haven't seen anybody run the ball on the
tampa bay buccaneers all year long other
than your minnesota vikings they're the
only team that's legitimately
consistently got to run ran the ball on
them all year as good as the packers run
game is you know i don't i don't know if
i can sit here and think they're gonna
be able to run the ball successfully you
know i think the packers i think it's
gonna have to be aaron rodgers to carry
the team and win it and like you said
you know the bucks their team i mean
it's damn good the only really weakness
you can look at and and it's not even
that weak is that young secondary that's
all you can look at
the first time around he got sacked four
times like you mentioned and one thing
what going back and watching that game
mike that stuck out to me man the
packers just kept calling deep throws
down the field everything was deep deep
deep deep and he's sitting there patting
the ball and of course they're getting
pressure every play they never really
adjusted
the bucks
they've lost five games this year and
really four out of the five are against
teams who threw the ball quick and got
the ball out of their hands and picked
apart their zone coverage
i'm gonna go the bucks get three plus
sacks i am because i think rogers and
company are gonna have to throw the
football i could see him getting sacked
four times i don't think it necessarily
means they lose the game or anything
like that but i think he is gonna have
to throw the ball to win so i'm gonna go
with the bucks getting those three sacks
and i love the subplot in this one with
ndamukong sue and aaron rodgers rogers
told pat mcafee earlier this week he
doesn't expect much conversation with
sue
when they played in week six they they
it got a little chippy between the two
of them and rogers thought they were
going to talk after the game and they
didn't and just be careful that sue's
feet don't get cold because if they go
numb you never know where he's going to
plant his cleats aaron rodgers so get up
off the ground quickly and watch out for
sue's numb
feet and the cleats attached to them one
more bucks packers actually a couple
more tom brady more likely that he's
throws three or more touchdown passes or
has one or more interception against the
green bay packers no risk it no biscuit
chris how does that play out i know you
know they've really become a team where
it's you know run the football
block it up play action pass you know
brady's decision making has been so damn
good
you know i want to say
the three plus touchdown passes right
off the bat but the only thing that like
makes me back away from that a little
bit is i just think they might run the
ball in the end zone you know a few
times that that's where
so again
i i i wouldn't be shocked if both of
these quarterbacks had three plus touch
three touchdown passes in this game
i don't think brady's gonna throw an
interception i'm gonna go you're making
me pick i'm going three touchdowns
i'm gonna say he's gonna throw an
interception you know we forget about it
once they win the game there was a
moment where he threw that out route
that looked a lot like the one that was
a pick six week one against the new
orleans saints right marshawn latimer i
think it was had a shot at it this time
and it bounced off his hands and he had
to lunge forward it's not like he was
going to grab it and go right but
there's just that
and and i think this makes
tom brady even more compelling for his
accomplished as he is as skilled as he
is as smart as he is
there's that little glitch that will pop
up from time to time that makes you say
what the hell because he's the last guy
you expected from but he's got that
propensity and i don't know if he just
gets a little lackadaisical he gets a
little complacent he's not focused on
every snap but every once in a while
chris am i wrong there's like one of
those what in the hell this is tom brady
type of a moment i i feel like yes and
and especially when you talk about that
and correlated this year it's it's those
moments where
you know he's not comfortable that's
what i look at it where he's just oh you
know we we've we've talked about it on
sunday where he can be a little you know
the start of the game he's jumpy and
he's kind of like flinching and dunking
ducking in the pocket and you're like
wait nobody's around you just relax you
know and that's where i feel like his
mistakes have come all year long but the
bucks have done an amazing job in making
him feel comfortable and we've seen less
and less of that as the year went along
to where
like you're right i hear your point it's
always been there but i i don't know i
just don't see it happening this weekend
with the way they're executing and
playing on the offensive side
you know that's a point that that you
brought to light for me a few years ago
when eli manning was getting toward the
end and the clock accelerates because
you're not getting the protection you
end up getting rid of the ball more
quickly than you should even when you
don't have to right and and the more
that the bucks can protect tom brady the
more he can settle into that rhythm and
that there's just there's a rhythm to it
there's a sense to it you know when the
walls are closing and you know when you
need to move you've been there and
you've done it so many times and if you
feel rushed if you feel like you're
about to get to get splattered by a guy
who's less than half your age that's
when maybe you you make a throw that you
shouldn't have made all right another
one from bucks packers and this is the
last one what's more likely mike evans
rob gronkowski and antonio brown have
over 15 combined receptions or under 10.
and remember we don't know what's going
to happen with antonio brown but last
week
evans gronk and brown had one catch each
yeah this is uh
man this is a tough one here it really
is
you know what i do worry about as far as
the packers defense in this game
is them
losing the battle at the line of
scrimmage and then having to you know
put more assets into stopping the run
game and just
it's too easy of a pass look for for
this tampa bay offense and things like
that
but without brown playing
and everything i'm gonna go i'm gonna go
oh man under 10 that's ridiculous
i'm gonna go 15 plus then i am i don't
know i can't go under 10. i i just have
a hard time thinking mike evans doesn't
get around seven or eight receptions in
this football game and gronkowski at
least getting three or four to go along
with it
especially after last week yeah right
especially with only one now it was a
touchdown but i think evans is going to
be more focused and more determined
gronk i don't know gronk still looks
like he's running in mud to me a little
bit yeah he doesn't have that explosion
but i think evans he's never been this
far in his career he's kind of had this
quiet
early hall of fame type of an effort in
the nfl the only guy in nfl history with
seven straight seasons of a thousand or
more receiving yards this is his moment
and this is what we see we see guys rise
up to the moment yep or not rise up to
the moment i have a feeling he's one of
these guys who's gonna rise up to the
moment i think so too and i don't think
the green bay packers can play the same
defense the new orleans saints did last
week you know the greatness of what we
talked about early in the week and what
tampa did was we never seen bruce arians
be so patient with the run game and
everything you know the saints because
of their big d line
played like too deep the whole game they
basically just caught they were trying
to call the bucks bluff and the call the
bucks called it back on the america all
right fine we'll run it we're not going
to be scared of your d line we got a big
o line too and that took away evans in
the passing game i don't think the
packers can do that i don't i don't
think they're good enough up front to be
able to say we can play too deep and our
big guys will slow down the run game
they're gonna have to get some
one-on-one matchups and it'll be on jair
alexander and kevin king to stop those
evans evans and godwin and everything
like that so that's where i think they
could have a big day passing
let's flip it now to the afc and when
the
bills and chiefs got together also in
week six it was one of those prime time
games on a tuesday night or monday night
i think it was the first of a monday
night it was a monday night right it was
one of the double headers um
that night
the chiefs rushed 46 times it was tied
for the most ever by an andy reid
offense with the two thousand eagles in
week one and it was the only time in
patrick holmes career where kansas city
had more rushing yards 245 than passing
yards 221. that's the build up for this
what's more likely kansas city rushing
for more than 150 yards or under 100
playing that bill's defense for the
second well wait no you missed the first
one with the mahomes has over 350
passing yards or
you know you just but but why don't you
just you just go along with it i did
miss it but if you just answer that one
then i'll pick that one up next that's
how it works okay
don't put the whole breaks on this show
all right don't take it so personal i
was just telling you don't worry all
right fine
casey runs for one we'll go to that i'm
not sitting here sipping pina coladas
i'm trying to work okay all right well
read better then and then you'll work
better ac runs for 150 plus rush yards
or under 100 yards
i'm going under 100. i don't think
kansas city is going to play that same
style of football again you know that
was a part of the year where buffalo's
defense was beat up and everybody was
running on them you could basically run
to the weak side on buffalo and you and
me could have got four yards per carry
every week against them they had issues
they are not the same defense anymore
and i think kansas city would be stupid
to play that way again i really do you
know you kind of took the air out of the
ball you took the air the ball out of
the best player on your team so uh the
bills defense much better than they were
then and i just can't imagine kansas
city running the ball 40 times in this
type of game or the bill's letting that
happen so i'm going to go under 100.
yeah i would appreciate very much if you
don't talk about taking the air out of
the ball in advance of an afc
championship yeah well i'll do my best
yes i really would like to avoid any of
that conversation okay i agree with you
the chiefs are going to be under a
hundred i i i rushing i i think that
that you know the bills are going to be
ready for it as part of the chess match
that's going to go on between andy reid
and sean mcdermott how much are they
going to run how much they're going to
pass and i also think that to the extent
rushing yards may be contributed by
patrick mahomes i think they're going to
be a little more careful with that this
week toe injury and given the concussion
all right speaking of patrick mahomes
and the
the topic that i inadvertently skipped
as we pivoted to the afc championship
game patrick mahomes has over 350
passing yards or under 250 his third
lowest of the season was 225 against the
bills in week six i'm gonna go 350. i am
um
this is this is the bills
they know they got to stop patrick
mahomes and that type of stuff and all
of that you know early in the year there
the chiefs they ran the ball but really
ever since that game too they were in
the process of realizing how to throw
the short passing game and do some of
that stuff more it was very similar to
the bills actually to where i think
they'll be able to run the short passing
game
the buffalo is gonna have to take a few
chances here and there yeah i i just
think this is gonna be a totally
different game than the first time
around where the first time around it
was running it was rainy it was
different i think this game you're gonna
see
both teams go nope our best players are
our quarterbacks and we might throw at
every play and that we're going down
swinging with our best punch so i'm
gonna go with the 350 plus
yeah i agree with you it's patrick
mahomes and it's legacy building time at
an early stage of his career the
opportunity to get to a second super
bowl he's going to use his arm to get
there so i'll agree with you there how
about josh allen your boy blue the
bill's quarterback what's more likely he
has over 350 or under 250 passing in
this game against the chief oh
he had 122 i know against the chiefs
when they played in week six i know the
the chiefs defense is is better to me
than the bills you know the chiefs can
play coverage and do those things
and let their big guys up front stop the
run even though the bills don't run the
ball that much anyways and i don't
expect them to do that here in this in
this week but again under 250 to me is
just i don't see that happening these
are two guys that you know they can get
250 on three throws
you could be sitting there going oh
we're holding them in check and all of a
sudden things explode in the third
quarter and you go whoa they threw
through 250 in the third quarter so i
think again if i'm gonna pick either one
here and where the buffalo bills offense
has been executing you've talked about
so much how josh allen's just got an
aura of like you're not gonna beat me
and all that i think they're gonna throw
the ball every damn play this week too
for the most part so i'm gonna own over
350 for him too
okay so then i have a feeling i know the
answer to the next one and i agree with
you it's good i i and part of me is
trying to kind of
speak and wish it into existence
right quarterbacks over three figures
mike let me ask you
i was just going to say with the
quarterback conversation because he
talked about like rogers and brady and
that dynamic there you know
uh i don't know this is just me the
football fan fanboy mahomes allen you
know i love both of them i think we both
do allen i guess has more pressure on
him right here in this situation like
mahomes doesn't have pressure on him but
i do feel like
mahomes
is slightly threatened by josh allen i
don't know why i just when i hear him
talk about him josh allen's challenging
him to the long throw competition and
all those things i
when i hear him ask questions about josh
allen i feel like he doesn't talk as
nicely as he does maybe with other
quarterbacks i just wonder if that's a
real element i feel like josh allen the
first time around
he felt the pressure of whoa this is a
prime time game and i need to be as good
as patrick mahomes and he missed some
throws and do all that but i just find
that to be an interesting dynamic of
these two i don't know if you feel the
same way
i think the pressure is squarely on my
homes you do they're the team that's the
defending championships they're at home
right josh the bills have already
exceeded
anyone's reasonable expectations could
have been they're on house money and
something about them changed coming out
of the bye week after they lost to the
cardinals in the hail murray they had
the four straight nationally televised
games big platform they were beating the
crap out of everybody now they've had
two more playoff games in isolated
windows they're comfortable with this
moment
i think that there's more pressure on
patrick mahomes and if your perception
is right that he feels a little
threatened by josh allen we could see
a little of that patrick mahomes trying
to do too much that's what i think about
it that's what could make things
problematic for the kansas city chiefs i
i just i that's why i kind of brought it
up i think about it with both of these
quarterbacks where even if like mahomes
got up josh allen might be like i gotta
match him and now he's trying to throw
lasers into triple coverage down the
football field i just something
interesting and when you're used to
being
the man and no i'm the most young
talented guy
i'm the the unicorn
you know and then you start to go wait
somebody else is calling another guy a
unicorn they think he's a mirror mirror
on the wall right it starts that's when
it gets personal when you start to go
wait wait i want to beat this team and
be in the super bowl but i also want to
beat this damn quarterback and show
everybody too that that's just something
that jumps out to me and something we
talked about recently and there is a
very real vibe that is beginning to make
the rounds in the nfl
that if you had to pick between allen
and mahomes for the next 10 years a
surprisingly high people
are saying alan whispering allen because
we've already been conditioned to think
mahomes is going to be the greatest of
all time when he's done and he very well
may be and i hope he is but but
people are seeing what josh allen has
done this year in his third season and
saying holy crap
the way he throws the way he moves and
you know i i've been told there's a
fundamental difference
when you see it live yes with bro with
josh many people when you're in the
building right and you see it happening
live and how he moves and how he can
roll right and throw back to the left on
a laser and there's it's just so much
more impressive live that's what's
causing people number one games who
fought and then that's what's that's
what because people are like oh come on
it's patrick mahomes what are you
talking about every time i turn on tv
there's patrick mahomes right green
beans with troy palamala right josh
allen campbell no it's it's the gap is
closer than people would think and and
maybe maybe maybe the guy who didn't get
to be the top dog for very long is
already feeling the heat well i mean i
doubt that quite yet but i think he
recognizes talent and he he watches
every game of everything i mean he's
always tweeting doesn't matter what
sporting event so he's i'm sure he's
watched josh allen and gone whoa
this guy's a little threatening to me
he's damn talented and he does a lot of
the damn stuff i do mahomes is cooler
and slicker and things like that but
mike
consistently over the last year i've
heard that from a number of coaches to
what you're saying
you know i didn't realize he was this
good until i turned on the film i just
didn't realize it and then whoa i mean
hey have you ever seen josh allen in
person man you know again he's a much
bigger man than mahomes and he's just as
fast and as quick and his arm is every
bit as strong he might not be as cool
and as slick and do the sidearm stuff
quite as much but i i like you said to
echo your point i think it's more of a
conversation than nfl circles than than
maybe the the you know casual fan
realizes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports